After all, you need real materials to make something that's real,
but I think you'll understand that when you see it being made.
[Music]
My name is Yutaka Sasaki, and I started working in Eko when I was
18. That's
why.  After
studying only blowfish for about 45 years, I think it would take
at least 10 years to create the authentic taste that we have today.
However,
both males and females have blood, so it's
not good to have transparent tetrodoxin mixed in with blood.I think there
are many people who have never had the luxury of eating sulphur.
That's why I think it's a feeling to want to eat Fu at least once.I
can't explain the magical taste, but
it's delicious, delicious, and beyond
delicious.
In the case of blowfish, there is no oil, and it is a comprehensive art, and
if you use a wonderful vessel, it will make you feel more
motivated.The
difference between work and work
[music] is that you can
really save people's lives.  It's
absolutely safe, and you'll know it when you see it being made.
[Music]